durante o dia de hoje
nós tivemos muitas oportunidades é de
muitos exemplos para mostrar como o
mundo está repensando a educação neste
mundo novo que nós estamos construindo
as idéias são maior tesouro ea única
certeza que nós podemos ter é que a
gente não pode ter certeza de nada é e
esse mundo novo exige uma nova educação
uma educação que promova a dissonância
em vez da conformidade a colaboração em
vez da competição
a criatividade a ruptura ea autonomia em
vez da passividade da submissão e da
repetição
em resumo uma educação que tenha por
objetivo produzir um novo em vez do
mesmo
a boa notícia é que ao mesmo tempo em
que esse mundo novo nos desafia mudar
ele mesmo vai lhes oferecendo as
ferramentas para essa mudança é na
frança um milionário chamado chave l é
dos 70 milhões de euros para a criação
de uma escola de engenharia
o meu francês é péssimo e eu treinei
bastante para poder falar o nome dela
que direitinho e cólica rendón
esqueça tudo o que você sabe sobre
escolas na casa do não há livros nos
laboratórios
não há aulas e nem professores apenas
três coisas alunos desafios e as
ferramentas para que os alunos supere
esses desafios computadores conectados à
internet
os desafios são dificílimos como por
exemplo é desenvolva um sistema de
reconhecimento de linguagem capaz de
identificar automaticamente em que john
webb site da escrito 40% dos alunos que
entram na casa andando não tem ensino
médio completo
ainda assim depois de seis meses
eles são capazes de superar desafios
como esse sem aulas sem professores
aprendendo uns com os outros
os alunos devem ensinar uns aos outros o
que sabem e pesquisar juntos o que não
sabem para superar desafios como esse
um exemplo mais conhecido é a escola da
ponte em portugal quem chamou a atenção
do brasil para ela foi o grande rubem
alves que nós perdemos recentemente ao
contrário da canoa escola da ponte é uma
escola de ensino fundamental como é que
todos nós freqüentamos só que
completamente diferente
em primeiro lugar ela não tem turmas
separadas por idade o que permite que os
alunos mais velhos
ensinem aos mais novos em segundo
a relação entre aluno e professor é
oposta à que nós estamos acostumados
o aluno decide o que deseja estudar e
escolhe um tutor para lhe auxiliar em
terceiro lugar
não há exames com datas fixas obrigando
todos os alunos a concluírem os estudos
sobre determinado assunto no mesmo
momento
quando o aluno acredita que dominou o
conteúdo que estava estudando
ele pede para ser avaliado se a
avaliação confirma que ele aprendeu é
ele pode passar o tema seguinte caso
contrário o tutor e auxilia a obter o
conhecimento que estava faltando
mas a mim como designer interessa
principalmente os exemplos que mostram
como design
tá podendo contribuir cada vez mais para
uma nova educação 22 deles são a cada
meio por será o samba cantando aquela km
já nos mostrou como vídeo-aulas
estruturadas em um sistema simples mas
projetado de forma inteligente podem
revolucionar o ensino da matemática
concedendo a cada aluno
o poder de avançar no seu ritmo sem
precisar ficar parado marcando passo em
algo que já entendeu nem ter que deixar
para trás
algo que estava com dificuldade e que
acabou ficando sem aprender porque o
professor precisava passar próximo
assunto
a dafne cólera de parceira já mostrou
como o design pode contribuir pra
conceder acesso livre e gratuito a
cursos de nível superior ministrados por
grandes professores a milhares de
pessoas no mundo todo
mas além de designer
eu sou pai eu tenho outro papel muito
importante na minha vida sou pai de uma
menina adolescente que está prestes a
entrar no ensino médio
isso significa que ela só vai ter mais
uns três anos na escola e por mais que
eu esteja otimista eu não acredito que
essas mudanças vão chegar tão rápido a
tempo de beneficiar diretamente a
clarice e os filhos e netos de muitos de
vocês fazem parte da última geração de
alunos da escola do passado alunos que
ainda que vão sentir na pele mas que
ninguém
a diferença entre a realidade para a
qual estão sendo preparados ea realidade
que eles vão realmente enfrentar eles
são alunos que ainda estão sendo
preparados para uma revolução industrial
mas vão ter que liberar uma revolução
digital
por isso há um tempo atrás eu escrevi
uma carta para ela com alguns conselhos
para tentar ajudar ela a lidar com essa
situação e eu queria aproveitar a
oportunidade para repetir alguns desses
conselhos aqui pra ela
até porque não é todo pai que tem a
oportunidade de projetar conselhos para
sua filha numa tela desse tamanho
então vamos lá
clarice não deixe que a escola que
ensine que conhecimentos podem ser
compartimentadas fragmentadas separados
em caixinhas isolados uns dos outros mas
fora do passado
a matemática acaba quando começa a
física a geografia acaba quando começa a
história uma campanha toca ea biologia
taboa
começou no mundo a biologia no esporte
a matemática na música a história da
literatura a gramática na programação de
computadores
então depois de estudá lo de perto de
sempre um passinho para trás
enxergo todo e perceba as relações não
deixe que a escola que ensine que alguns
conhecimentos são mais importantes do
que outros na fé é a escola do passado
uma forma de medir a importância que nós
damos algo é o tempo que nós dedicamos
essa coisa na escola do passado para
cada aula de artes a duas de geografia
para cada aula de geografia a duas de
matemática sabe dos beattles dois deles
foi uma carta e george harrison foram
colegas na escola
eles estudaram juntos lá e tiveram aulas
de música na escola juntos durante
muitos anos e durante todo esse tempo
nenhum professor percebeu o enorme
talento que eles tinham
pelo contrário eles eram considerados
maus alunos porque o mal nas outras
disciplinas
imagina só metade dos beattles em salem
al amal de música durante anos e ninguém
percebe que há algo especial ali
por sorte eles persistiram
mas imagina quantos grandes artistas e
esportistas já não abandonar os seus
talentos porque o conhecimento que lhes
interessava não era o mesmo que
interessava à escola
persigam os teus interesses mesmo que
eles não interessa é mais ninguém
não deixe que a escola que ensine a
decorar
além do cérebro nós temos outra
característica que foi fundamental na
evolução do ser humano
algo que parece ser bem mais simples mas
que é importantíssimo o nosso dedo
polegar para e pensa quanto os animais
que consegue lembrar que são capazes de
manusear ferramentas segurar algo que
lhes ajude a passar a se defender a
construir abrigos a se locomover
o ser humano dominou o planeta porque
foi capaz de construir e utilizar
ferramentas que estendem os limites das
nossas mãos e dos nossos pés
agora nós construímos ferramentas que
estendem os limites do nosso cérebro
nós podemos carregar no bolso da calça e
imensa as memórias adicionais e podemos
acessar as memórias uns dos outros
instantaneamente
isso significa que nós não precisamos
mais desperdiçam no cérebro como um
imenso depósito de datas nomes e
fórmulas
nós podemos usar todo o potencial dele
pra analisar refletir e criticar o mundo
de informações que nós podemos acessar
com um clique
esqueça tudo o que puder
a internet é o teu hd o cérebro é o
processador não deixe que a escola que
ensine que provas são capazes de medir a
sua inteligência
cada vez que você abra os olhos escutar
o som toca em algo sente frio ou calor
os seus neurónios crianças finados
eles se conectam os outros pra registrar
essas sensações
isso significa que você aprende o tempo
todo o teu cérebro cresce até
inteligência cresce o tempo todo e é
impossível medi algo que não pára de
crescer
além disso como as suas experiências são
únicas da inteligência também é única
mas tem uma vez disse que se você julgar
um peixe pela sua capacidade de subir em
uma árvore ele vai passar a vida toda se
considerando um estúpido
as provas da escola do passado servem
para julgar quem é mais adequado
do passado
não deixe que a escola que ensine a se
contentar com pouco
assim como as provas fazem com que quem
tirar notas baixas do vídeo de si mesmo
elas também dá uma péssima edição
prossegue também tiram notas mais altas
da mesma forma que elas ficariam como o
aluno quem tira 45
elas costumam apontar como mediano que
tira 67 e como excelente o que sempre
tira nove ou dez toques só que tem uma
armadilha e as consequências de tirar 71
10 são exatamente as mesmas não lembro
de estudar muito e praticamente só tinha
10 até a 5ª série
quando as matérias começaram a ficar
mais difíceis eu acabei de ano 88 meio
a princípio eu fiquei arrasado mas logo
percebi que isso não fez a menor
diferença eu passei de ano exatamente da
mesma forma e aí no ano seguinte eu me
contentei com 86 acabei tirando set
quando eu comecei me contentar com 7 eu
tirei 65 e eu demorei muito tempo para
desaprender essa lição
isso não significa que você deve ficar
arrasada se depois de se dedicar muito
algo não obter um bom resultado mas
nunca tenha média como objetivo o menino
tem o melhor sempre no mundo fora da
escola a excelência faz toda a diferença
não deixe que a escola que ensina
acreditar que ela é suficiente
a escola do passado lamentavelmente
abdicou da missão de preparar os alunos
para o futuro e se limita a tentar
prepará los para o enem e para o
vestibular mas a tua vida produtiva
começa exatamente a partir desse ponto e
para ser bem sucedida nela você vai
precisar de muito mais do que ciências
matemática português história e
geografia
o futuro vai exigir que você tenha
consciência global para entender o seu
papel mundo que você entenda os seus
direitos e deveres para poder cumprir
seu papel de cidadã que você domina a
internet enquanto ferramenta de
você tem uma boa noção de economia para
poder gerenciar o teu dinheiro que você
tem a noção de empreendedorismo para
fazer as suas ideias virarem realidade e
muito mais
muitos desses conhecimentos você não vai
encontrar na escola
procure os onde eles estiverem
não deixe que a escola tem sim que você
não tem nada ensinar na escola do
passado
as crianças são separados em séries de
acordo com as faixas etárias
isso praticamente impede a interação
entre alunos de idades diferentes mas os
seus colegas um pouco mais velhos têm
muito a ensinar e o que é ainda mais
importante os mais novos têm muito a
aprender contigo
aí colocando ea escola da ponte são
exemplos de que ensinar é a forma mais
eficiente de aprender quando um
professor detém o monopólio de ensino
ele te rouba inúmeras oportunidades de
aprender ensinando ensinar aprendendo
nunca perca uma chance de ensinar o que
você sabe é não deixar a escola que
ensina ser apenas uma consumidora de
idéias
a escola do passado costuma se limita a
ruminar as ideias dos outros
praticamente não há espaço para que os
alunos produziram pensamentos cria
idéias é gerem seu próprio conhecimento
eles diariamente aula após a aula
mastigam embora gerem um enorme cardápio
de informações
eu fico imaginando quantos professores
da escola do passado já entraram na
comunidade de fãs fixa milhares de
adolescentes que na escola provavelmente
são taxados como desinteressados
produzindo literatura
lendo os textos dos outros criticando
compartilhando o mundo do futuro é o
mundo da troca
neles mais bem sucedidos não serão os
que forem capazes de acumular mais
ideias mas sim os que forem capazes de
distribuir mais
escreva desenho e cante danse filme blog
fotografe pinte borg
produza e compartilhe o mais importante
de tudo minha filha não deixe que a
escola que ensine que aprender é a mesma
coisa que ser ensinado
toda criança nasce uma esponjinha de
conhecimento louca pra absorver os comos
e os porquês de tudo que vê essa fome de
conhecimento costuma durar até o exato
momento em que ela pisa na sala de aula
na primeira série da escola do passado
a partir dali que ela começa a ser
convencida de que aprender não é mais
sentia experimentar e sujar as mãos de
terra e tinta como ela estava acostumada
agora aprender sem estar silenciosamente
em cadeiras alinhadas à busca do
aprendizado começa mais no nas
interrogações dos alunos mas nas
afirmações do professor ela não começa
mas na dúvida mas na resposta ela não
começa mais na curiosidade mas na
autoridade a criança não está mais no
comando do seu ato de aprender
ela não é mais o sujeito ativo do seu
ato de aprender é um sujeito passivo do
ato de ensinar do professor ela
em resumo não mais aprende é ensinado
mas viver é aprender e você tem
autonomia ou seja a liberdade ea
responsabilidade para decidir o que
aprender e portanto como viver não a
seda a ninguém
se você pudesse ensinar a evitar que a
escola que ensina essas coisas você vai
acabar percebendo que a tua vida de
aprendizado pode ser muito maior mais
longa mais produtiva mais rica e mais
divertida do que a tua vida escolar
então vai ter a vida toda para desfrutar
dessa incrível era do conhecimento que
está só começando
te amo obrigado